tonight police are searching for the
mother of a seven-year-old boy who was
found dead in mountain springs more than
a week ago
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis metro police
are now able to identify the little boy
as liam houston his mother was last seen
in denver
orcomanna joins us live from in studio
with the very latest on this
investigation at 11. orco
well brian and denise metro police say
liam houstead was killed
and his body was left in a desert hiking
area 10 days ago
there's now a nationwide arrest warrant
out for his mother
samantha marino rodriguez both are from
san jose california
but the investigation spans at least
three states
there's a lot of moving parts to this
investigation metro police identifying
the boy found dead near mountain springs
trailhead on may 28th
as seven-year-old liam houstead of san
jose there's now a nationwide search for
liam's mother
35-year-old samantha marino rodriguez
who's considered a suspect in his murder
police say she may be driving a 2007
dark blue dodge caliber packed with
belongings
we don't know a possible motive metro
police say a family friend recognized
one of the previously released sketches
of liam that friend went to san jose
police who then reached out to metro
using the child's clothing metro's
forensics team made the positive
identification
over the weekend this has been an
emotional last 10 days for
myself all the investigators that have
been working on it
and we're just glad we're able to get
some closure for liam
and then hold the person responsible for
this crime accountable
police say liam and his mother left san
jose on may 24th on may 26th they can be
placed in the laguna beach area
and in victorville later that afternoon
liam's body was discovered on may 28th
in mountain springs the next day
marina rodriguez's car was seen
traveling on i-70 near grand junction
police say she was last seen on may 31st
checking herself into a denver area
hotel metro believes she is traveling
alone and they need help from local
hotels
please check their hotel register for
the days
of the 27th and 28th to see if samantha
checked into a hotel
here in the las vegas valley
now here is another look at samantha
marino rodriguez and the vehicle police
believe she's driving
again it's a dark blue dodge caliber
with license plate
6 wlh
anyone with any information about where
she could be is urged to call metro's
homicide section at 702-828-3521
you can also call crime stoppers to
remain anonymous brian
orco thank you we are going to continue
to monitor all of the developments
closely as police search for the boy's
mother
check in anytime for updates at
8newsnow.com as well as all of our
social media pages